536 the fremont street experience is of
course a major attraction for us here in
las vegas and for tourists takes
hundreds of people to manage it all
there's a lot of people that have to get
managed there bianca holmen live this
morning downtown to share some details
about a job fair if you want to work at
the experience
bianca yeah that's exactly right so
fremont street experience it is six
blocks of entertainment dining
there's gambling there is so much that
people do enjoy when they're down here
shopping of course
and like you said it takes lots of
people to manage it all and so there is
a
job fair that is happening today and
we've got the details for you now here
goes some more information at the start
of the pandemic the group had to
furlough 200 people
they hired back most but some found
other jobs or
circumstances changed so they've got
openings positions like slot zillow ride
operators sales associates
facility crew members and security
officers are
needed the human resource director tells
us there's no experience needed
and they will train you
we're looking for is people that enjoy
the job
enjoy people we have guests from all
around the world
like you said it's a very diverse crowd
that we have we have a very diverse
workforce
so we like you know safety of course is
number one for our employees and our
guests
but we want people that enjoy their work
we want them to enjoy their work
and make our guests have a wonderful
experience here at fremont street
experience so that they continue to
return again and again
all right now take a look at your screen
these are the details for today's event
it's from 2 to 4 this afternoon
if you're interested apply online before
arriving
and you got to be 18 years or older and
provide a current
resume and again they also tell me that
for some jobs they'll hire
on the spot and for others there may be
a second follow-up
coming up in the later weeks so
reporting live from the fremont street
experience bianca holman
8 news now